round eight of the London chess classic  the live stop on the grand chest tour  with the finish line in sight in the  tour title at stake the pressure was on  for the world's best players desperate  for a win world number one Magnus  Carlsen was pushing for victory against  co-leader Yana bacchiocchi but a  shocking series of mistakes ruin the  champs position leading to a painful  loss I just put the pom I'm afraid I  didn't see that he couldn't take it on  till after I put it that gave his  opponent a golden win leaving the  Russian star in Seoul first going into  the final round  yeah because pressure is only because of  Issa there's one more round to go and I  mean of course I'm in a good situation  right now but everything that can happen  I believe there's everything to play for  with titles on the line the exciting  finale of the season-ending classic  starts right now